we're learning about a new expedition to
study great white sharks the ocean
research group oh search say they'll be
going to a new region to study sharks
and we can reveal that cbs mornings will
be joining them later this month off the
coast of nova scotia dana tony i'm
signing you up their goal is to find and
tag 100 great white sharks they've
already tagged 84. this helps
researchers understand shark behavior
and health oh search founder and
expedition leader chris fisher joins us
right now good morning chris how are you
doing
good morning how are you thanks for
having me
of course so why do you call this
expedition the last um part of the white
shark puzzle
well there are eight white shark puzzles
around the world and we are solving all
those puzzles because as the white shark
goes the ocean goes
and so we are in the middle of wrapping
up solving the puzzle of the white
sharks that live off the east coast of
the united states as well as atlantic
canada and we are just about to wrap
that project up identifying full
migration birthing and mating and so
forth so we can manage the white shark
so we're wrapping up off the east coast
in the western north atlantic and the
next puzzle to solve is over in the
mediterranean starting next year
so what are you learning about them
right now as you're tracking about where
they are that is going to help us in
some way
well what we're learning about what's
going on this time of year is the sharks
have just endured a long winter they're
skinny they've been off the southeastern
united states and the gulf of mexico and
they're migrating north to the
northeastern united states and atlantic
canada
to forage on seals to bulk back up like
many animals do so they can endure the
oncoming winter so everything's moving
north right now we have animals strung
out from around the carolinas all the
way through and up to newfoundland uh
far north of the northeastern united
states and in the next few weeks or so
they'll all be up north focusing on
putting pressure on those seals so the
seals don't wipe out our fish stocks and
bulking up for the oncoming winter
and osearch was part of a study that
found that sharks are they're staying
closer to shore when it comes to being
near big cities
do we know why and what does that mean
for people that are getting in the water
potentially well it's not just the big
cities you know there was a big
misconception about white sharks for
many years that they were these open
ocean wandering animals when we started
our work about 15 years ago and began
putting more modern tagging technology
on on those animals we began to see that
the white sharks are actually very
coastal uh they're really moving from
event to event which means if there's a
big bait run in front of a river an
estuary they will be up and in that if
there's a fish run they'll be on it
they're obviously on the seals when
they're up north so before it was
thought they were more of a pelagic
animal an offshore animal but that's
just not the case they're super coastal
we've all been swimming with them all
our lives nothing's changed we just know
now
you know one of the realities of uh
going into the ocean is that you were
stepping from the habitat that we all
inhabit the land and talk about what is
like the habitat of the sharks we are on
their turf at that point and shark
attacks well very rare they do happen
they happen where i go in the summer in
cape cod they happen off the coast of
long island recently in california and
hawaii
what can people do who want to swim
maybe want to learn to surf and still
feel safe in the water
well i think the biggest thing is you
know when you head down to the beach
and you're and you're thinking about
safety in regard to sharks because
there's a lot of other safety issues
with drowning and rip currents and
everything else but when you're focused
specifically on sharks you know you want
to approach the ocean the same way you'd
approach going on a hike in the forest
you want to look at it first you want to
understand the environment
that you're going to be playing in with
your family so that you can be
personally accountable for your safety
and your family's safety if you see
things like birds crashing on the water
bait moving around
game fish crashing on that bait then the
sharks are going to be on that too and
you don't want to swim out into the
middle of the food chain you want to go
find a quieter section of beach i think
the biggest thing that's really going on
right now is that we've had this
incredible return to abundance off our
both our east and west coast we are
winning our fish are coming back our
whales our turtles our seals and our
sharks of course there's more life in
the ocean now than has been seen since
the 40s or 50s
all of us grew up with a compromised
ocean we grew up with an ocean that was
heavily christmas we gotta go gotta get
going here thank you so much